de signer un protocole avec l'état pour
cette fermeture anticipée
on parle également de flamanville qui va
coûter 10 milliards d'euros
et là on va mettre 450 millions sur la
table pour fermer un outil qui
manifestement fonctionne qui à
l'autorisation des autorités de sûreté
nucléaire et sans absolument aucune
compétence aucune plus aucune
compensation pour les collectivités
locales qui sont totalement oubliés et
les deux mille salariés dont on ne parle
pas non plus on a beaucoup parlé hier de
luire poule à amiens pas un mot sur les
2000 salariés qui vont perdre leur
emploi
du côté de fessenheim par cette décision
du président de la république qui nous
surprend quand même par sa va falloir la
fois ça ça sa brutalité et surtout la
veille d'élection présidentielle on sait
que cette dose peut encore changer avec
ses échéances nationales
merci eric straumann voilà le feuilleton
de fessenheim qui n'est peut-être pas
terminée puisque en cas d'alternance la
droite annonce déjà son intention de
revenir sur ce processus
exactement nous y reviendrons avec et
benoist apparu en autriche